welcome back the left's outraged mob
worked themselves into hysterics this
week when the president said that he'd
be the one who decides when to open our
states back up of course he went on to
say that his decision would be made in
conjunction with the state's governor's
but the left didn't let that
inconvenient fact get in the way of
their narrative
he's proclaimed himself a king they
cried out what about the 10th amendment
it's obvious that these Democrats
haven't even read the 10th amendment if
they did they'd realize they'd have to
throw away about half their platform
here's what the 10th amendment actually
says the powers not delegated to the
United States by the Constitution nor
prohibited by it to the states are
reserved to the States respectively or
to the people take note Biden Cuomo and
the rest of you Virtue's signaling
trough hating elitist this means there's
no role for the federal government in
health care education or housing just to
name a few so say goodbye to your plans
to expand Obamacare your plans to give
everyone free college and your plans to
make banks give out risky mortgages you
use taxpayer dollars to expand the
federal government in a hundred
different ways every day now you're the
ones lecturing us about that Tenth
Amendment give me a break
the American people see right through
you we here on this show on the other
hand truly believe in decentralizing
power and we're planning a big campaign
on it so stay tuned for that